Julie is with us in Pittsburgh hi Julie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
a question I have for you is I am
completely debt-free proud mom for
children and an amazing husband who has
been diagnosed with a terminal illness
cancer we have some amazing things that
has transpired since then
canta has been one of those things that
it's been our biggest reason for praying
and our biggest blessing as well and
with that being said we have close to
not close to I know exactly how much we
have we have fifteen thousand seven
hundred dollars in savings all of our
ordinary and customary bills that we do
as a family like gas electric all those
things are taken care of by individual
rental properties now with cancer coming
into place we even have a rental
property set up to where it covers our
vacations and things like that my
question is should I start a non-profit
or should I take our rental property
that I take care of our vacations and
should I liquidate it and put those
funds into savings in cases we
experienced any huge cost from that I
know that my max out-of-pocket for an
annual year can be $15,000 yeah how old
is he my husband is 50 and I'm age 38
and we have children that are age three
four six sixteen and also an adult child
who's 27 does he have life insurance I
know we went ahead and prepaid he
doesn't have any life insurance no
prepaid what prepaid for those final
expenses for doesn't have
a life insurance policy that you will
get money should he moves away okay
yeah and your homeless paid for
absolutely
and how many rental properties do you
have seven and soon to be a net worth
should be right around nine hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that by the end
of August
okay the rental properties are all
debt-free yes sir
okay so there's small properties yes sir
I mean on average they bring us in
anywhere from seventy to eighty thousand
dollars a year yeah okay all right and
that's how you will eat should something
happen to him yes sir okay but you know
there's not life insurance but there is
a lot of a lot of paid for real estate
you got a million dollar net worth
basically yes sir okay
so should I start a nonprofit a
nonprofit is of no value you can't use a
non-profit for your own use violence tax
law and so right but but are you
collecting are people giving you
donations is that why you're willing to
start a non-profit there there has been
folks that have reached out to us and
just truthfully you know we're used to
paying for everything ourselves and not
really having folks come to us in that
way yeah what was I'm pretty so for that
you're talking about selling it would be
one of those smaller smothers I can pick
for many of them but I'd probably start
with start with the one that brings us
in the least amount of rent and that's
four hundred and fifty dollars a month
we could get I would say a fair market
value for that one would be about fifty
thousand dollars yeah through this a
little bit okay
if you only have fifteen thousand
dollars cash and instead you had sixty
five thousand dollars cash because you
sold that property that would give you
cash gives you power it gives you
options when you're facing tough
decisions okay and so if you decide you
need to get on a plane and fly to
wherever to get a treatment that maybe
insurance does
cover I'd want to have that money
available yeah and yeah and then your
you know in a best case or a worst-case
scenario worst cases you spend the money
doing something like that and and it
doesn't work that'd be your worst case
scenario but if in the case that you
don't use the money and he's okay his
health comes back you would just take
that money and buy another rental
property in the case that if something
happened to him and you hadn't used that
money you could just take that money and
buy another rental property so we've not
really lost anything except maybe a
little bit of capital gains tax or
something from selling yeah it's gonna
be milliner because it's a minor sized
property the whole thing's not gain it's
only what you've gained that's gained
and that's only at fifteen percent and
so you're not gonna I think you want the
cash position to fight the battle of
your life okay
cuz you're in the battle of your life
right and you know there's a part of me
that definitely wants to be financially
responsible but there's also that part
of me too that once they capture those
moments and you know we're living in the
- right now you got your birth date you
got your end date and you get the - in
the middle was where talent so you know
that's why I was really struggling with
getting rid of the vacation you know the
one that provides us with education
vacation each year so would you say that
taking it one thing you know one thing
about being where you guys are it makes
the - really clear yeah we're just here
for labor we're just here for a moment
that's right and I know it's gonna be
born again and to heaven and I know that
heaven is the best vacation you could
ever take but at the end of the day I
want to make sure that we get lots of
pictures with these babies and their
daddy hey Mel yes yeah you draw it you
drop a little coin on that listen here's
the thing let's say it out loud this way
okay you you don't you don't talk like
this
and so I know you don't think like this
but you're a millionaire yes sir you
have a net worth of a million dollars
yeah go on vacation your husband has
cancer okay do it absolutely do it okay
you're being very you're being very wise
you've been very strong and you've got
real good spiritual clarity you got
wisdom beyond your years just talking to
you you're gonna be fine
but you're in it you you guys have put
yourself in a position to fight this and
and to tend to take clear advantage of
every moment of that - okay and listen
you call me if you need me okay I'm here
all right I appreciate it mr. Ramsey
thank you so much and God bless I'm not
mr. Ramsey I'm day Dave's okay all right
Dave I appreciate you have a good day
all right okay I just got clarity for
the rest of the day Wow living in the -
and so are you and so am I
you